thank you very much for the introduction
Pete and I feel very glad in order to be
here to give the presentation and
introduction of the work we have done
with the Microsoft so again I myself I'm
from Microsoft cloud and AI organization
my name is Ola John and I'm in the data
science tear science to here and I'm
based in Singapore so today the topic
I'm going to discuss about this
recommendation right so so basically is
a open source project we have been
working closely with a lot of you can
see here the acknowledgment right so
they are basically from different teams
within our organization their
researchers twelvers suffer engineers
and their scientists so yeah this is the
objective so taken recommendation
technology to the masses so actually the
this was inspired by one of the
exhibitions from a museum a pop pop
culture in Seattle so actually the
original statement is taking the pump
punk music to the masses so that was to
like the respect to the very famous rock
band of Nirvana right so we are actually
we have been inspired a lot by this kind
of statement because we talked about the
air technology we want to like you know
make sure that everyone can benefit from
that right it's not like you know the
regulation or whatever technologies is
just something like you know withheld by
the big companies like Microsoft or
Google whatever right so it doesn't make
sense so this is why we want to like
make sure that after we we have you know
open sourced everything about the
recommendation study or research we want
people like researchers developers they
can you know benefit from the repo to
like prototype or demonstrate or even
put things into production for their own
use case right and the key takeaways of
the talk is add and actually the the
talk here is
is a little bit technical it can also be
a little bit academic but I would say
that all of these are the state of the
arts and all of these are the things
that I want to share with you because
these are the core technologies in my
opinion that are used to eating a lot of
the recommendation system in the
nowadays industry so the outline will be
that first of all I would just give you
a very very brief overview of the
recommendation technology and how this
technology is used in the modern
business and then after that I will talk
about the recommendation algorithms and
the implementations so all of those
things I will talk about they are
available in the recommendation
repository we had two of it and then the
third one I will talk about some and -
that example I mean these are the
real-world examples that can make sure
the recommendation algorithms can be put
into production system especially by
using our Microsoft Azure platform and
then maybe there'll be several minutes
for question and answers
okay so recommendation in baden-baden
business so we know that actual
recommendation can be found everywhere
so if you take a look at all of the
logos here so they're a bunch of bunches
of companies that apply the
recommendation a key terminology to like
boosts to their own business like for
example Microsoft if you're aware the
big news and being other search engine
actually they have been applying a
recommendation technology for a long
time right so several other use cases
like if you are aware of the e-commerce
or entertainment like the video
recommendation or powder recommendation
so it's almost everywhere when you open
your app you go to the website you can
see a lot of for recommendations here
and there so that you can you know these
recommendations going to be personalized
and they can be precisely you know
directing you to the right place where
you can find the things that are
interesting to you so what are the
problems they are trying to solve when
they apply the recommendation technology
so basically there are three things
so the first one is that the you know
the the I so called the right um
recommendation right so if this is the I
would say the more October
my knowledge but so the items here can
be referring to a brand news product
depending on what kind of industry you
know the recommendation is used for and
basically it's just like recommend a
certain item based on the historical
interaction results between the users
and items and the second one is the
business metric partition like a lot of
times we talk about for example ads
right
so you can predict how the ad
advertisement of your whatever can be
improved by using the algorithms so
recommendation technologic can be used
here for predicting let's say you have
ass of an image or whatever forms and
maybe the algorithm can like help you to
figure out where you can pull the image
on your website so that the the sort of
the internet metrics like a CTR can be
maximized and the last one is the
customer segmentation and
personalization the personalization so
this is more of relative to the
marketing campaigns right so for example
your phone to like targeting our product
precisely to a group of people you want
to like apply this kind of technology to
do that however whenever we talk about
the recommendation there are I mean
according to my as well as my team's
experience working with the customers
and clients so there are basically three
challenges in general so the first one
is that there there's a very limited
resource for people to like reuse to you
know in order to establish your
recommendation system so these can you
know this can refer to like the
reference or any guidance or especially
the industry level guidance
no I'm not talking about academic
research paper we could because you know
if you go to archive you can see a lot
of publications every day but I don't
think all of them can be used to
practically into your production system
so what I want to say is that there's
very limited references for you to like
from a pragmatic point up a personal
perspective how do you like develop a
recommendation system in a very
efficient manner right so this is first
challenge the second one is that
although we can also find some packages
like libraries
anything that has been published on
github or wherever however they are very
fragmented so it means that is hard to
like you know for example you can find a
lot of algorithm implementations off the
shelf but if let's say you want to make
a whole system I mean it's just a lot of
different parts but algorithm
information is just one part of it so
how can you you know aggregate
everything together in order to make a
whole system that is a very challenge
and the third one is that the error is
growing very fast and is changing all
the time and as I said I mean if you go
to the academia research paper if you go
to the community you can see that a lot
of people they're talking about new
algorithms every day right so later on
I'll go through a few algorithms to just
demonstrate that how the field is that I
make ok so then this is the motivation
why we want to have this kind of open
source effort that can you know resolve
the issues I have listed in the previous
slide right so this is something we call
a Microsoft a recommender so it's
basically a github repository and if
let's say if you go to the github
repository you can see that this is like
you know you can find all of the code in
Canada you can find all of the
references text and explanations and the
entering examples that can really help
you like resolve a lot of issues that
may you know block you in the in the in
a way to production lies your
recommendation system so this is a
collaborative effort between Microsoft
data scientist team as well as research
team and also some external academic
researchers they have participated into
their project as well and a provides a
bunch of very cool algorithms including
the classic algorithms like matrix
factorization as well as the new ones
like how do you use the deep learning
technology to build a new types of
recommendation system that are you know
specifically working for a particular
task right and so
a few highlights about the project is
not actually so far in it was open so
last year in December and now if scott
serese Alden actually is 3,800 plus
stars in github so and also it was
featured in YC hacker news or relateed a
newsletter and also it was once in the
list of the github a weekly trending now
trending list okay so again I mean if
let's say your open source community
developer or if you're interested in
contributing to the repo just feel free
to go to the repo to go to get up to
like create whatever issues you found
like when you you know either work with
the repo or you just go to a repo and
you can just create any PR if you think
you can like improve the recruiting
whatever way alright so let me just go
through the recommendation algorithm the
implementations so first of all I I
would like to ask actually I actually
have asked this one at the beginning of
the talk so how many of you are working
recommendation okay great and have
worked in recommendation okay yeah okay
all right so all right so then I would
just try to make it a shot because some
of the algorithm are maybe a little bit
more advanced it in yeah so whatever I
mean recommendations so we know that
when we talk about recommendations they
are typically two types of
recommendations so the first one they
so-called labra Ritz who filtering
collaborate if you're trained right and
the second one is that actually I have
already added to the slide on my about
but I I just didn't have the chance to
update the was so the second one is the
content-based filtering right so later
on I will show you how different they
are
and basically we have this bunch of this
bunch of algorithms for collaborative
filtering and content-based filtering so
collaborative filtering so when we talk
about recommendation less
take a look at the figure here right so
suppose this is one like yourself and
you have to watch you have watched a few
movies right so let's say this we want
and maybe your friends a and B and a C
they have watched some other movies
right so the logic of collaborative
filtering is that the algorithm will try
to like analyze the similarity between
your premises and your friends
preferences and then sort of you know
find the similarity and analyze how
close that you know the the friends
preferences are to your potential
processes right and then those
potentially interesting movies where we
recombine it to you so it's very simple
I mean is something away collaborative
filtering is because you know within the
population of all of the users teachers
clapper relatively final to the
similarity across all of the users and
their recommended items right so then
there are several basically two types of
measures for collaborative filtering the
first one is the memory based so again I
mean the memory based algorithm
technically it is far the similarity and
save that into the matrix and then use
the matrix to give you the
recommendation results right well the
second one is the model based measured
model based a mess or solve the problem
in a motion learning type of approach so
it means that you just try to like find
out the similarity and develop a model
that can optimize the the last function
right so you for from below is the
concept in machine learning so the last
function is your Lee the objectives that
you want to optimize in your problem so
in you know model-based measures you
earlier like in the recommendation
scenario the the same stat is going to
be optimized is for that both the
ratings of the movies or the ratings of
the products or the ranking like the you
know a list of the items that are
relevant to the user so this kind of
thing right so the model based masters
they're trying to solve this kind of
problem
and there are many many different kinds
of model based measures so one of the
classic
very representative Messrs it's called a
matrix foundation right so if you're
aware of the mathematical term is
basically based on the single single er
value decomposition right so this is the
basic method that is used to form a
standardization and then people come up
with some other advanced technology that
can result that the efficiency issuing
optimizing the lectures factorization
problem so that's called ALS alternating
Lister Square and also this can be
implemented into spark which are more
scalable so this is the first type of
mixer cyclization and also a lot of new
techniques that you know Sprott these
years they try to use the deep learning
technologies to to build the
collaborative filtering type of models
for example the researcher postman
machine and neural collaborative
filtering right so again this is the
member Messer I don't want to go through
all of the formulas here but I want to
just simply introduce you that so the
the core idea of the memory based
approach is just to calculate the
similarity like for item or for users
right depending on what kind of
scenarios you're trying to apply the
recommendation algorithm Inc right and
surely the similarity calculation method
is for example Pearson or cosine
similarity then after that he can use
the similarity scores to recommend that
items I mean you can just like sort of
for ranking order the scores and then
recommend the items or the to the users
are recommended the users to the items
so I want to like go into some details
about algorithm that is invented by
Microsoft is called a smart adapter
recommendation actually it's a very
super simple idea so it's just like
again it's a type of memory based
algorithm so it's just try to analyze
the implicit feedback data which means
that suppose that we have a lot of
interactions with the items and how you
can
utilize that as historical data to
recommend the items so remember the
uniqueness of the problem is that you
don't you don't have the writings here
right so you don't have to burn a poll
you know from some of the data you know
let's say I'm DB right so you could go
there you can see a lot of our ratings
to the movies but these kind of problem
there's no such kind of rating
so how to do that so it's very simple so
you can still you build items item
similarity matrix so this is done by
calculating the co-occurrence of the
items let's say there are several items
they appear together to the user and
then they'll be counted right so this is
the way to like build an item times and
similarity matrix another very important
matrix is the user to item affinity
matrix so this is something to represent
how a user likes a particular item so
this is done by you know again very
simple counting the Corcoran's between
the user and the item like for example
how many times you have purchased this
product and then they'll give you the
score by using this account right but
another thing that is very important to
mention here is that because when we
talk about the recommendation we know
that for example this guy he has
purchased the item last year and then he
purchased again this year
or maybe something different this year
right so the the point here is that
actually the Preferences reflected from
his purchase behavior in the recent you
know month or days that will be more
important so that will be with it more
in our recommendation problem settings
right so this is why it in the affinity
matrix calculation the the time decay is
introduced to to model this kind of
effect right so then when you do the
recommendation actually is first
approaches to the matrix multiplication
between the items similarity and a user
fallacy and then you can have all of the
recommendation scores
you wrecked the scores and you get to
the top K items in the you know top
ranking of the list and then you just
use that as the recommendation so what
are the benefits
is very simple right as I have
introduced just now is it actually is a
memory based algorithm in the first
place
so it's free from machine learning you
don't have to train your model you don't
have to like to know have a parameters
disease and that so it's just you know
calculating from the data and they can
generate the results and also it doesn't
require you to collect other features
and the best part of the algorithms that
is explainable because you know for
example this guy has pushes this item
for many times and most of the pushers
happen in the you know last month right
so you can sort of explain this is why I
recommended items to to help again right
so this is the point but the
disadvantage is that actually the
calculation itself can be expensive and
also you have to you know preserve the
the affinity matrix as well as the item
similarity matrix so both both of them
can consume a lot of memory especially
when you have a very big data center so
imagine that you have a lot of items a
lot of users so this can be the
challenge yeah so here I've also shown
some code examples in how to use the so
called the star algorithm from our repo
so it's very simple like just exactly
how you do with other passing packages
like you can import a package from the
repo and you can just import import the
the the method to build a model and yeah
so this is the first part you can just
prepare the data set and failure model
generate the top key recommendations and
then do the evaluation by a few offline
evaluating metrics like the precision
decay and DC grk blah blah blah right
okay so let's move on to the next one
yeah so this is the matrix factorization
so just now we're talking about memory
mass our time so then the model-based
method one of their classical
representatives is a measure of citation
so I idea is very simple game
I mean it's just too like for example
you have the user item matrix
representing the data ratings so the job
is to like factorize this matrix into
two vectors right so what is the user
another is movie so that you can you
know when you do the product of the two
vectors you can sort of reconcile the
original matrix then you can have all of
the ratings predicted from the two
vectors right so this is the the idea is
very simple so I don't want to spend too
much time on that and but one of them
more advanced always actually this is
one of the very recent research so this
will called the neural collaborative
filtering so it tries to solve the
problem from the matrix my realization
that when you deal with the implicit
method I remember last just now I
mentioned the implicit feedback a dot
right so that is the data where you
don't have to express a ratings between
users and items you just have the
interaction right and for this kind of
thing the author point out of the
problem that when you have these kind of
settings actually when you put it into
the light and space the there there can
be some problem because you cannot fully
represent the relationship between each
of the factors so that is why he
introduced the something called
generalized the major factor a layer by
using the new attacker and your neural
network technology right so this can
sort of result that issue that existing
that existed in the original matrix
intelligent base are based a method
right and then to you know sort of model
the the high order interactions in the
in the data it also introduced the you
know multi-layer perception in the
neural network as well so they then he
put the two things together and the
footing to the last layer of the you
know activation function to produce this
course and in the training part he also
suggest a few loss functions like log
loss or other type of loss in order to
fit the actual problems so again I mean
in general the advantage of this
algorithm is that it leverages the the
benefit to neural network in order to
resulted the issue of their original
algorithm so then the second category is
something called a content-based of
filtering
so content-based of filtering is
different from the collaborative
filtering is that it actually use it the
features to predict that the writings or
any other labels in the recommendation
algorithm so for example you know this
guy is his age his gender his occupation
or other meta information about the
person or you know the futures of the
items and then you can use all of them
in order to predict whether this guy
likes at the movie or not or you can
predict even the experts are ratings at
them the guy into the on the movie right
so this is your this is the euro setup
of the content based algorithms so again
I actually you're looking for a model
that can sort of fit the input data you
which is your lay encoding in this way
in to like predict the label which is
binary label or the american raider
label so a few algorithms the first one
the most representative content based
ephemeral algorithm that is used to
nowadays it's called a factorization
machine right so as you can see that
these are the features and you have ones
zeros representing different types of
features so here's the movie data you
can see that the user ABCD there are
different users movie and these are the
Pyro's ever vision of the titles and
Jenner's or whatever information right
so then they organize that area in this
way to predict the target why here so
these are the ratings so the idea is
that actually it introduces the high
order interaction between the the
features right so the winner of doing is
this is that when you do the
factorization we do the know not about
the fraction when you do the for example
linear regression you cannot have the
interaction between the features right
so so this is why the first traditional
machine is trying to do that right again
I mean I don't think I have enough time
to to go into the details but
this is your li nowadays I mean a lot of
Industry applications many of the
algorithms are based on this kind of
file many of the applications they are
based on this algorithm ok and then on
top of that people like come up with new
technologies from FM so they are for
example a more product for introducing
the interaction of the features and
Google they have come up with the wide
and deep so they just have two parts one
is the interaction part another one is
just purely the linear regression and
then they aggregate them together and
train the model to get more getting much
better result for particular
applications and also deep FM they
introduce deeper neural network in order
to have some more high other
interactions so also one of our
colleagues from Microsoft of research
Asia they also have developed the new
algorithm called extreme deep
factorization machine right so they want
to have even higher order interactions
so that the iterative li-like introduce
the part between the inputs and the the
output from the input by introducing
some pooling layer ok then the whole
idea is that we just combine everything
together including the one I introduced
trista is called something called a
compress interaction network and linear
part of the the sayings together so that
they can have a better prediction result
so also a lot of times people are
talking about you know knowledge graph
so knowledge graph can be used for
recommendation as well because it can
have much more useful information for
the items and users so a few techniques
used for knowledge graph is that you can
basically introduce the embedding and
used embedding into your neural network
in order to have a better prediction
results and especially although in this
work and I mean the deep knowledge of
where network is not mentioned but a lot
of times the knowledge graph is also
used for enhancing the explained ability
of the recommendation
sit up okay so the last part is to enter
an example I just want to quickly go
through that one so okay yeah so just
now I talked about a lot of the
algorithm but in reality that the time
and effort spent on building a
recommendation system in my opinion
there there are actually something like
this I mean you spend most of their time
on preparing the data and you know
cleansing your data the order to make
sure data can be used to for building
the model well the algorithm is actually
a small part right another important
thing is for recommendation is the
evaluation and the last one is how you
can put everything together into the
system that's called operationalization
all 16 right so these are the four major
parts for building the recommendation
system and how do we do that so when we
do the operationalization we we do the
data collection dinner preparation and
model building so you know model
building one thing I would like to
highlight here is that yearly for the
recommendation is very very important
let's say if it's modern based algorithm
it's very important to find you in the
parameter in order to make sure the
model is optimal and then deployment of
the model you can either use kubernetes
container or you can use large
distributed database in order to host of
all of your data in a very efficient way
right so this is an example of a
real-time recommender by using
distributed database actually this is
done on actual cosmos TV so if you're
interested again I mean just go to the
github repo you can check all of the
details well here I just give you a very
high level overview of it and then the
next one is the the cooler editors so
I'm not sure if a fellow of the
technology I believe so but what I one
highlight here is that in the
recommendation system there is your Li
two typical scenarios one is the real
time scoring real time recommendation
another one is you cache that data into
AI cache the results into the database
and
use your holster service to fulfill the
recommendation so both of the two will
rely a lot on your this part I mean the
serving part was usually based on the
kubernetes right so you need to you know
properly configure the cluster in order
to make sure everything works well so
this is everything put together and as
your platform you can have a
recommendation system architecture like
this right so you use spar to train the
model generate the results and put it
into cosmos DB which is that distributed
database and then the kubernetes actual
kubernetes services it just fetch that
the precache that results from the
database to to serve the user clients
right and over here the actual machine
learning service is something like to
again just now I mentioned that you need
to fine-tune your model you need to like
orchestrate the pipeline so Azure
machine learning service is just
something like this to help you do that
okay so this is some load testing on a
real example so I don't want to go
through the details yeah so summary
again I mean the talk is really give you
a basic understanding a systematic
review a overview of how recommendation
works and what are the the classic and
state of tars algorithms and how we do
the end-to-end example on a sure to
build a recommendation system so I was
again I will highlight that if you're
interested you for you feel once we have
more exploration on the recommendation
technology just go to our github repo
Microsoft is slash recommenders and go
through all of the notebooks or utility
functions and even the reference
architecture examples to have a better
understand of life all right thank you
do I still have time to kick ass